Hello, and welcome to another
episode of GDL-IL--
GDL Israel.
Today, we're going to speak
about Big Query and Apps
Script, and how you could
leverage those two amazing,
powerful technologies in order
to get some clever insights on
your own big data.
Now I didn't prepare any
slides today, because I
thought code would be a much
more appropriate tool for a
crowd of developers.
So without further ado, let me
share my screen with you, and
show you what we are
going to do today.
So first of all, we're jumping
right into the things.
But maybe we'll take
a step back.
And we'll open another tab here,
just to show you what we
are talking about.
Yes.
And when we're talking about Big
Query, the best source to
start and try to understand what
we have on our heads is
the ability to gain insights
from your big data.
And when we're saying "big
data," we're speaking about
gigabytes, or terabytes,
or petabytes of data.
And anyone that works in, let's
say, a startup, mid-size
company, or a bigger
organization, knows that
there's lots of logs,
lots of data,
that is sitting somewhere.
And there are true gems
in this data.
And basically, it's quite hard,
in most of the cases, to
ask the right questions, and
to get a response in a time
that will make sense.
Luckily, Google Big Query is a
technology that lets you do
exactly that, and analyze
your massive data sets.
And the nice thing about it is
that you have this browser
tool-- that I'll show in a
minute-- and a command line
tool that let you play, quite
quickly, with the data, even
before you start approaching
the API and start building
your project that will create
some useful tool for your
organization.
Luckily for us, you could
go today-- and I'll
make it a bit bigger--
and the sign up is
just right here.
And it's open, now,
for everyone.
So you don't need to have any
invite, or any betavite.
In our little case, you
chose the [INAUDIBLE]
--that's importing the HTTP
archives, where we have the
ability to ask some [INAUDIBLE]
on the web, and
how we could get insights
about what's
going on with web data.
So when we're coming to this
browser tool, you can see
quite quickly that we have the
ability to go and to have
those public samples.
I'll make it a bit bigger.
It will be easier to read.
And in our case, I'll just
choose Wikipedia, but you have
lots of other things.
And first thing, we're
getting the schema.
If we go to the details,
immediately, you could have,
first, just the grasp of what is
the size of this data, and
when it was created, how many
rows we are talking here--
in our case, north of
300 million rows--
and how this table
is composed--
so all the different
characteristics that you could
later run a query on.
Here, I prepared and we have,
here, a query history.
A simple query, that if
I'll click on it--
let's make it a bit prettier,
and make it larger.
So this query is getting
the top 10 sites--
sorry, 10 articles--
that where revised frequently.
And we want to see just what are
those articles that people
have changed them again,
and again, and again.
When we are running, you see
here, we're getting how many
seconds it's taking.
And here in our case, to go and
to count over north of 300
million rows took 2.4 seconds.
So, quite impressive.
And here, if I just take this
line and make it bigger, you
can see a few of the
popular terms.
Quite funny that the list of
World Wrestling is very, very
high, considerably.
What we want to show today, and
that's something pretty
cool, is that the HTTP archive
is basically a site that just
gathers what is going
on the web.
As we know, it's important
to see how things are
progressing, how things are
moving, what are the trends,
if it's going forward
or backwards.
We want to make sure that we
know, and we have a way to
analyze it.
And this great initiative is an
open source project that I
was lucky enough to contribute
to in the past.
And all the data here is,
of course, downloadable.
So you could take it with
you, and analyze it on
your own free time.
The only problem is that
it's more than 400
gigabytes of data--
so, like a magnitude of 10
times what we saw just a
minute ago with Wikipedia.
There are a few interesting
trends, and slides, and stats
that you can see here,
on the site, itself.
But of course, it's much more
powerful to analyze and to
have the ability to query
it on our own.
So if we go into the browser
tool, we have here-- and
you'll need to edit.
And I'll have a post that
gives you all the little
details of how you could edit
to your project, later on--
But you have, here, basically,
all the runs and all the data
that you would want
to query later.
And again, in our case, I
prepared a short query that--
it's a bit longer, as
you can see here.
But let's make it a
bit more readable.
Basically, I'm querying
on June and July.
But for our example, let's
keep it just for
June, and run it.
And what I want to see in this
query is which are the most
popular sites--
basically, APIs--
that are being used
by other sites.
So in this case, you can
see quite quickly--
let's make it a bit bigger.
And now let's--
--quite well that Facebook
is in the lead.
And then, you have Google, and
Doubleclick, and Google
Syndication, and Google
Analytics leading the chart.
Of course, you could
save this table.
You could download it, and work
with it off this browser
tool two, and then
other tools.
And it's a quite nice way just
to see what we are doing, and
how we are going to
approach the data.
Now the big, nice thing about it
is that, with App Script--
and this is the example
that I prepared--
we could take the same thing
that we saw just now, but
automate it, and automate it
quite quickly and easily.
And how we are going
to do it--
I'll just show the
code [INAUDIBLE]
maybe we'll just jump
in and see what the
results look like.
So I composed this data from
the code that we have.
And as you can see here, I have,
here, a new menu item
that allows me to run
those queries, and
get the data here.
And after I'm getting the data--
for instance, in our
case, I just wanted to see which
are the top 10 sites
that are being used by others.
But I wanted to run it on
the previous 12 months.
So I wanted to see some
sort of a trend.
Is the usage going to
a certain direction?
Does it move up?
Does it move down?
And here, I just used the
charting to take a few bold
examples like Twitter, Google
Analytics, and Facebook.
And as you can see here, it's
taken just a bit of time.
But you can see quite nicely
that, maybe here at the
beginning of 2012, the HTTP
archive wasn't crawling the
same amount of sites that
it's crawling today.
So we see quite a
nice ramp up.
But you could definitely say
something about the end of
last year-- so around November,
December, 2012.
And then up to today, we see
that, in February, we had a
bit of a drop down.
And then, you can
see the trend.
Another interesting aspect is
Google Analytics, of course.
You can see it very
steadily going up.
And now, it's a bit flat.
And Facebook--
and here, it's mostly
Facebook CDN--
it's quite different, because
I just moved the bar here.
Why?
I think, because of the way
the data was sorted.
But you can see clearly
that it's going up.
Then we had some drop at the
beginning of this year.
And now, the trend
is quite flat.
So it's quite nice and
interesting to see
trends that are going.
Let's jump into the code,
and just go over it.
So the first function here is
a quite basic initializing
function that will trigger when
we open the Google sheet
that we have right here.
And it will just add a menu item
that we saw right here.
So this is the menu item,
as you can see here.
Now I hope that you can
still-- yeah, OK.
You can still see it.
So we have this menu item.
And let's jump into the code.
So this code just added
this menu item.
And it's letting us run,
basically, all the different
queries that we want to run.
And here, I have another query
that just allows me to run all
the queries that I have
under my hand.
So it's a very useful
way to just--
let's say you have a daily
dashboard that you want to get
insights, and to run your
several queries, and then, get
the results back.
It will be quite nice to have a
function to just gather all
the queries, and make sure that
you are generating them
with one entry point.
And here in our case, it's the
query, or the function, that
will give us the results of
which are the top 10 sites--
or APIs, actually--
that are being used by third
parties, over time.
You can see, here, that I'm
getting a default of where I
want this data to be output on
the sheet, itself-- so what is
the starting row, and
the starting column.
Then, I have this unique
identifier to my project.
And if you want to mimic it,
you'll need to go to the
console on Google APIs, and make
sure that you're creating
a new project, and
you're allowing
yourself to run Big Query.
I'll have, again, all the
details on how to do it in the
blog post that I'll publish just
after this GDL session.
Then, we get the handler
on that active
sheet that we have.
In our case, it's this
guy-- third parties.
And here, we just dump
all the raw data.
Here, I have all the dates that
I want to, basically,
query against.
Another fun part is here, where
I'm just building the
SQL and making sure that this
SQL is composed from several
SQLs, that each and every one
of them is just going on the
certain file, and fetching
the information from
the specific file.
If you saw, before that,
we were gathering
the files per month.
So pages and requests would be
gathered on a monthly basis.
And then, when we query them,
it's a much more efficient way
to go month by month, and
get the results back.
So after we compose this nice
SQL variable, we'll create
another query results object.
And in this try/catch block,
we'll just go to Big Query
object, jobs, and set the
query with the project
identifier in our SQL.
The beauty, here, is that this
object, now, will run the job
in the background.
And once its completed,
it will return us
getJobComplete() == True.
What we want to do, here, is
just run on this loop, and
make sure that we are fetching
the results just
when this guy is true.
And if it's, of course, not,
we'll just keep trying.
Now we are just setting some
boilerplate metadata on the
query, itself-- how many
rows we go back, etc.
We could definitely dump them
into another sheet, and get
some insights of what was the
metadata of the query, itself.
And last but not least, we're
just building the object of
dumping the result's values.
We get all the content that we
want to put on our sheet.
And then, we're just getting
the right range, and then
setting the values with
results' values.
Last but not least, we'll just
jump here, and, with the
message box, inform the user
that everything is done.
Let's see how it's run.
It might take a bit of time,
but we'll run it.
I'm just choosing the function
that I want to run here--
in our case, it's
this function--
and then, I'm clicking run.
As you can see, it's
now running it.
And if we come here, basically,
we're getting a
notification that something
is working.
And now you can see
that all is done.
We have all the answers.
And you see here, we have
fresh data that was just
produced from this specific
function.
The code will be,
of course, live.
Actually, part of this code is
already live on my GitHub
repository, and it's public.
So of course, I'll
have a link here.
But you could check out greenido
on GitHub, and get
different queries here, and of
course, all the boilerplate
code that I just showed
a second ago.
--case use for these types of
things is the ability to
create your own dashboard,
quite quickly.
And if you think about it, when
you have this big data
inside Big Query, you could
quite quickly go with App
Script, and create your daily
dashboard, get a trigger.
And here is a nice
ability to just--
sorry, just here, you could put
what your triggers are.
Make sure that, for instance,
we want to add a new trigger
that will run this specific
query on a specific event.
And this powerful thing will
give us the ability to
basically create new dashboards
that, once we are
fetching the data from the
query, we can emulate, we
could update the sheet,
and of course,
share it with our coworkers.
So that's what I
had this time.
And if someone would like to ask
questions on the chat, or
live, here, please feel free.
So I see one thing
from a developer.
They're asking if they could
run Big Query with other
languages and technologies.
And the answer, of
course, is yes.
We actually have lots of
libraries and clients that are
supporting almost, I
think, any popular
language that is out there.
A great way to start and check
how you could write with it,
and how you could work with
Java, Python, and others would
be to go to this page, and
just check on Big Query's
APIs, Big Query client
libraries.
And from here, you could see,
quite quickly, that we have
lots of client libraries for
almost any popular technology
that is out there.
So if there are other questions,
this is the time.
If not, thank you for joining
us, and we'll be here next
week with interesting
startups.
So be strong, and bye bye.